- Willkommen zurück zu „Quanteninformation
und -berechnung verstehen".
Mein Name ist John Watrous, und ich bin der technische Direktor
für Bildung bei IBM Quantum.
Dies ist die zweite Lektion der Reihe. Falls du die erste Lektion
noch nicht gesehen hast, schau sie dir unbedingt an.
Wir werden direkt auf dem aufbauen, was wir
in der ersten Lektion besprochen haben, daher ist es wichtig,
dieses Material zu kennen, bevor du mit dieser Lektion beginnst.
Beachte außerdem, dass die Reihe
neben Videos auch Lehrbuchinhalte umfasst, und einen Link
zu den Lehrbuchinhalten findest du
in der Videobeschreibung. Dies ist Lektion zwei von
Einheit eins der Reihe.
Einheit eins behandelt die Grundlagen
der Quanteninformation.
In der vorherigen Lektion haben wir über Quanteninformation
im Rahmen von Einzelsystemen gesprochen, das heißt, wir haben ein
System, das Informationen speichert,
und wir beschreiben, wie
es isoliert funktioniert.
Wir haben recht viel Zeit
mit klassischer Information verbracht, hauptsächlich um einen Referenzpunkt zu etablieren
und die mathematischen Gemeinsamkeiten hervorzuheben
zwischen Quanten- und klassischer Information.
Wir haben auch gesehen, wie Quantenzustände durch Vektoren dargestellt werden können,
konkret durch Vektoren mit komplexen Zahlen als Einträge
und euklidischer Norm gleich eins,
und wir haben Standardbasismessungen
und unitäre Operationen besprochen.
In dieser Lektion werden wir unseren
Blick auf mehrere Systeme erweitern, von denen jedes
Quanteninformation speichern kann.
Das ist nicht einfach eine Frage, ob jedes einzelne System
so funktioniert, wie wir es letztes Mal besprochen haben –
es gibt einen Sinn, in dem das Ganze
größer ist als die Summe seiner Teile, und das gilt
auch für klassische Information, wenn Wahrscheinlichkeiten
im Spiel sind.
Mehrere Systeme können
miteinander wechselwirken und sie können zum Beispiel
miteinander korreliert sein, und im Quantenbereich schließt das die Möglichkeit ein,
dass die Systeme verschränkt sind, ein Begriff, den du
vielleicht schon mal gehört hast.
Verschränkung ist ein sehr
wichtiges Phänomen in der Quanteninformation, und wir werden
noch viel mehr darüber sagen, wenn die Reihe fortschreitet.
Es gibt jedoch ein einfaches Prinzip, das uns
eine Menge Ansatzpunkte bietet, um Quanteninformation
für mehrere Systeme zu verstehen,
nämlich dass wir immer
zwei oder mehr Systeme nehmen und sie zusammenfügen oder sie
konzeptuell zusammen betrachten können
und sie so betrachten, als würden sie
ein einziges zusammengesetztes System bilden.
Und wenn wir ein solches
zusammengesetztes System so betrachten, als wäre es ein Einzelsystem,
erkennen wir, dass es auf eine Weise beschrieben werden muss,
die mit allem übereinstimmt, was wir gelernt haben
in der vorherigen Lektion über Einzelsysteme.
Wir werden sehen, wie das funktioniert
und wie die Beschreibung von Quanteninformation
für mehrere Systeme sich ziemlich natürlich daraus ergibt,
wie es für Einzelsysteme funktioniert,
basierend auf diesem einen Prinzip. Hier ist eine Übersicht der Lektion,
die zufällig identisch mit der Übersicht der vorherigen Lektion ist,
aber dieses Mal liegt unser Fokus
auf mehreren Systemen statt auf Einzelsystemen.
Genau wie in der vorherigen Lektion und aus genau denselben
Gründen werden wir mit
klassischer Information beginnen.
Auch hier werden wir
sehr enge Ähnlichkeiten zwischen der Art und Weise sehen, wie
Quanten- und klassische Information auf mathematischer Ebene
funktionieren.
Wir werden uns typischerweise nicht so sehr
auf klassische Information konzentrieren oder jede Lektion der Reihe
so mit klassischer Information beginnen.
Spätere Lektionen werden tendenziell
viel exklusiver auf Quanteninformation und -berechnung ausgerichtet sein.
Aber hier am Anfang
ist das ein sinnvoller Ansatz, und er geht auf die Idee zurück,
dass das Nachdenken über klassische Information
als wertvolle Orientierungshilfe für das Verständnis
von Quanteninformation dienen kann.
Wir werden auch
das wichtige Konzept des Tensorprodukts in
diesem Teil der Lektion besprechen.
Tensorprodukte sind von entscheidender Bedeutung in der Quanteninformation,
treten aber auch im
klassischen Bereich auf.
Dann werden wir zur Quanteninformation übergehen, und ähnlich wie in der vorherigen
Lektion werden wir Quantenzustände,
Standardbasismessungen besprechen,
und unitäre Operationen, diesmal
für mehrere Systeme.
Wir beginnen damit, über
klassische Zustände mehrerer Systeme zu sprechen.
Erinnere dich aus der vorherigen
Lektion, dass ein klassischer Zustand eines Systems eine
Konfiguration dieses Systems ist, die eindeutig erkannt
und beschrieben werden kann
ohne jegliche Unsicherheit oder Fehler. Und in mathematischen Begriffen meinen wir, wenn wir uns auf
eine klassische Zustandsmenge beziehen,
einfach eine endliche und nicht-leere Menge.
Wir beginnen unsere Diskussion
über mehrere Systeme, indem wir davon ausgehen,
dass wir genau zwei Systeme X und Y haben.
X hat eine Menge klassischer Zustände, die wir sigma nennen werden,
genau wie in der vorherigen Lektion, und Y hat eine Menge klassischer Zustände,
die wir gamma nennen werden. Die Mengen sigma und gamma
könnten dieselbe Menge sein oder unterschiedliche sein,
aber wir geben ihnen verschiedene Namen, nicht nur weil sie
unterschiedliche Mengen sein könnten, sondern auch weil es uns
hilft, die Dinge klar zu halten, wenn wir ihnen verschiedene Namen geben.
Wir werden feststellen, dass es
ziemlich einfach ist, diese gesamte Diskussion von zwei Systemen
auf beliebig viele Systeme zu verallgemeinern, aber indem wir mit zwei Systemen beginnen,
können wir uns auf die grundlegenden Ideen konzentrieren,
ohne uns in Details zu verlieren.
Stell dir nun vor, dass wir
X und Y nebeneinander stellen, X links und Y rechts, und wir betrachten
diese zwei Systeme zusammen
als ob sie ein einziges zusammengesetztes System bilden.
Um diesem neuen System einen Namen zu geben, können wir es als ein
geordnetes Paar schreiben, oder wir können einfach
die beiden Buchstaben nebeneinanderstellen.
Beide Varianten sind gängig und wir
können wählen, welche wir wollen oder welche gerade praktischer ist.
In jedem Fall lesen wir es als XY.
Eine sehr naheliegende Frage,
die man sich an diesem Punkt stellt, ist: Was sind die klassischen Zustände dieses neuen zusammengesetzten Systems XY?
Die Antwort darauf ist, dass die klassische Zustandsmenge von XY das kartesische Produkt der
beiden klassischen Zustandsmengen ist,
sigma und gamma, die du
hier direkt definiert siehst.
Zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt hat X einen klassischen Zustand,
der ein Element von sigma ist, und Y hat einen klassischen Zustand,
der ein Element von gamma ist,
und wir denken einfach
an diese beiden Zustände gemeinsam, als ob sie einen einzigen Zustand bilden – und genau das ist der Begriff,
den das kartesische Produkt erfasst. Wir haben zwei Elemente,
je eines aus unseren Mengen, und wir wollen
diese beiden Elemente zusammen betrachten,
als ob sie ein einziges
Element aus einer einzigen Menge bilden.
Um es klar zu sagen: Hier wird vorausgesetzt, dass wir wissen,
welches unserer Systeme X und welches Y ist,
und dass es keine Verwechslung zwischen ihnen gibt. Es ist nicht wichtig, dass X physisch auf der linken Seite
und Y auf der rechten Seite ist,
sondern dass die beiden
Systeme unterscheidbar sind und dass wir entschieden haben,
sie in dieser Reihenfolge anzuordnen, damit wir
den Überblick behalten, welches welches ist.
Hier ist ein sehr einfaches Beispiel, bei dem sigma das binäre Alphabet und gamma die Menge
der vier Kartensymbole ist.
Wenn X einen Binärwert speichert und Y eines der vier Kartensymbole, dann gibt es acht
mögliche klassische Zustände
des Paares XY, die du
hier direkt aufgelistet siehst.
Für mehr als zwei Systeme lässt sich dies auf einfache Weise verallgemeinern.
Insbesondere wenn X1 bis Xn Systeme mit klassischen
Zustandsmengen sigma eins bis sigma n sind.
Wenn wir uns dann vorstellen, die n Systeme zusammenzufassen und
als ein System zu betrachten, ist die klassische Zustandsmenge
das kartesische Produkt
der n klassischen Zustandsmengen
sigma eins bis sigma n.
Wie du hier auf dem Bildschirm sehen kannst. Das kartesische Produkt
kann so für eine beliebige Anzahl von Mengen definiert werden.
Wenn wir zum Beispiel drei Systeme haben und sie alle das binäre Alphabet als klassische Zustandsmenge teilen, wir also mit anderen Worten drei Bits haben,
dann gibt es acht
mögliche klassische Zustände der drei Bits, betrachtet
als ein einziges System, und du kannst sie hier aufgelistet sehen.
Jedes System einzeln kann
im Zustand null oder eins sein, und wir durchlaufen alle
möglichen Kombinationen.
Ein n-Tupel klassischer Zustände kann alternativ als Zeichenkette geschrieben werden, bei der wir
die Klammern und das Komma weglassen, wie du hier siehst.
Das ist besonders sinnvoll, wenn wir klassische Zustände als Symbole betrachten, wie im sehr häufigen Beispiel
des binären Alphabets,
auf das wir immer wieder zurückkommen. Manchmal ist es sehr praktisch, das so zu machen, und es macht
unsere Ausdrücke einfacher
und übersichtlicher. Der Begriff einer Zeichenkette wird tatsächlich in
mathematischen Begriffen durch kartesische Produkte formalisiert,
daher ist das wirklich nur
eine alternative Notation und nichts konzeptionell Anderes.
Als Beispiel nehmen wir an, wir haben
10 Bits X1 bis X10.
Das bedeutet, dass die klassische Zustandsmenge der 10 Bits zusammen,
die du dir natürlich als ein 10-Bit-Register
in einem Computer vorstellen könntest,
das zehnfache kartesische
Produkt des binären Alphabets mit sich selbst ist.
Und wenn wir diese Zustände als Zeichenketten schreiben, sehen sie so aus, wie du hier siehst; es gibt 1.024 davon,
also sind natürlich nicht alle hier aufgelistet. Diese drei Punkte hier
sollen darauf hinweisen, dass es ein Muster gibt, das du ableiten kannst,
und hoffentlich verstehst du die Idee. Nun gibt es eine Konvention,
der wir bei der Anordnung der Elemente
von kartesischen Produktmengen folgen werden,
und es ist wichtig,
dies für die Darstellung sowohl probabilistischer Zustände als auch von Quantenzuständen als Vektoren zu klären.
Die Konvention ist, dass
wir die Elemente kartesischer Produktmengen
lexikografisch anordnen, was im Grunde nur
eine alphabetische Sortierung bedeutet.
Genauer gesagt beginnen wir mit der Annahme, dass jede der einzelnen Mengen, von denen wir das kartesische Produkt bilden, bereits ihre eigene Anordnung hat,
und wir betrachten ein
gegebenes n-Tupel oder eine Zeichenkette so, als wäre es ein Wort, und
ordnen sie alphabetisch.
Eine andere Art, dies zu sagen, ist, dass die Positionen innerhalb
eines n-Tupels oder einer Zeichenkette von links nach rechts
an Bedeutung abnehmen,
genau wie wenn wir Zahlen mit den Ziffern null bis neun schreiben.
Hier ist ein Beispiel, das
das verdeutlichen soll.
Wenn wir das kartesische Produkt zwischen den Mengen, die
eins, zwei und drei enthalten, und dem binären Alphabet bilden, erhalten wir eine Menge mit sechs Elementen,
und hier sind sie in der
beschriebenen Reihenfolge aufgelistet.
Alle Elemente mit einer
eins an der ersten Position kommen vor allen Elementen mit einer zwei an der ersten Position, und diese kommen vor allen Elementen
mit einer drei an der ersten Position. Und wenn zwei Elemente
an der ersten Position übereinstimmen, greifen wir auf die Anordnung
an der zweiten Position zurück.
Das ist also die Reihenfolge, die wir
für kartesische Produkte verwenden.
Beachte, dass wir beim Verwenden dieser Konvention und beim Schreiben von n-Tupeln als Zeichenketten einige sehr vertraute Muster beobachten.
Das kartesische Produkt des binären
Alphabets mit sich selbst ist zum Beispiel so geordnet, wie du es hier siehst,
und du kannst dir diese Zeichenketten als numerisch geordnet vorstellen, wenn du sie
als binäre Kodierungen nicht-negativer Zahlen betrachtest,
und das verallgemeinert sich
auf jede Zeichenkettenlänge. Kommen wir zu probabilistischen Zuständen – wir wissen bereits aus der vorherigen Lektion,
dass ein probabilistischer Zustand jedem klassischen
Zustand eines gegebenen Systems eine Wahrscheinlichkeit zuordnet.
Wenn wir ein zusammengesetztes System haben, bei dem wir zwei oder mehr Systeme genommen haben und sie gemeinsam betrachten, als ob sie ein einziges
System bilden, wie wir gerade besprochen haben,
dann muss ein probabilistischer Zustand
dieses zusammengesetzten Systems den Elementen des kartesischen Produkts
der einzelnen Systeme Wahrscheinlichkeiten zuweisen,
also den klassischen Zustandsmengen. Das liegt daran, dass dies
die klassische Zustandsmenge des zusammengesetzten Systems ist.
Angenommen zum Beispiel,
dass X und Y Bits sind, haben wir dieses Beispiel eines
probabilistischen Zustands von XY.
Die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass beide
Bits null sind, beträgt ein halb und die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass beide
Bits eins sind, beträgt ebenfalls ein halb, sodass die beiden Bits nie unterschiedlich sind.
Es ist ein gültiger probabilistischer Zustand von XY, und wir können ihn alternativ
als Vektor schreiben,
wie du es hier siehst, und hier kannst du erkennen, dass wir
der Konvention folgen, die ich eben für die Anordnung dieser klassischen Zustände beschrieben habe.
Dies ist ein Beispiel für
einen probabilistischen Zustand, bei dem X und Y korreliert sind, und das ist der Sinn, in dem das Ganze
größer ist als die Summe seiner Teile. Wie ich vorhin angedeutet habe, ist es nicht so einfach, dass wir
einen probabilistischen Zustand
von X und einen probabilistischen Zustand von Y haben und sie zusammensetzen, sondern wir setzen die Systeme zuerst zusammen
und denken dann über
probabilistische Zustände des zusammengesetzten Systems nach.
Um Korrelationen zwischen Systemen
genauer zu beschreiben, beginnen wir damit, den
Begriff der Unabhängigkeit zu definieren, der im Wesentlichen die
Abwesenheit von Korrelation ist.
Hier bezieht sich der Begriff Unabhängigkeit übrigens
auf statistische Unabhängigkeit, im Gegensatz zur linearen Unabhängigkeit
von Vektoren zum Beispiel.
Es ist ein grundlegendes Konzept in
Wahrscheinlichkeitsrechnung und Statistik.
Wenn wir zwei Systeme X und Y haben und uns einen probabilistischen
Zustand von XY vorstellen, dann sagen wir, dass X und Y unabhängig sind,
wenn die Formel, die du
hier siehst, für jede Wahl klassischer
Zustände a und b von X und Y gilt.
Eine Möglichkeit, diese
Bedingung der Unabhängigkeit zu interpretieren, ist, dass sie besagt, dass die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass X sich in einem beliebigen klassischen Zustand befindet,
und die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass Y sich in einem anderen klassischen Zustand befindet, absolut nichts
miteinander zu tun haben.
Das heißt, wenn wir erfahren, in welchem Zustand
sich eines der Systeme befindet, beeinflusst das die
Wahrscheinlichkeiten für die Zustände des anderen Systems nicht.
Wenn du dir vorstellst, zufällig
einen klassischen Zustand von X gemäß einem bestimmten Verfahren auszuwählen und dann zufällig
einen klassischen Zustand von Y
gemäß einem anderen Verfahren auszuwählen, das in keiner Weise
mit dem für X verbunden ist – zum Beispiel wenn eine Person eine Münze wirft
und eine andere Person in einem
anderen Raum einen Würfel wirft –, dann ist das die Formel,
die du verwenden würdest, um die Wahrscheinlichkeiten
für verschiedene Kombinationen
von Zuständen zu ermitteln. Der Sinn der Definition ist, dass Unabhängigkeit vorliegt,
wenn die Formel gilt.
Wenn wir probabilistische Zustände in Form von Wahrscheinlichkeitsvektoren betrachten, gibt es eine einfache Formulierung
dieser Bedingung,
nämlich wenn wir einen
probabilistischen Zustand von XY haben, den wir als
Vektor in der Dirac-Notation ausdrücken können,
wie du es hier siehst. Dann ist die Aussage, dass X und Y unabhängig sind, äquivalent zur Existenz
zweier Wahrscheinlichkeitsvektoren,
Ket Phi und Ket Psi, die wir der Kürze halber
einfach als Phi und Psi lesen können, und die
probabilistische Zustände von X und Y getrennt darstellen, welche diese Gleichheit erfüllen,
die du hier siehst.
Für alle Wahlen von a und b ist es im Wesentlichen eine
Umformulierung der Definition in Form von Vektoren.
Hier ist zum Beispiel ein probabilistischer
Zustand eines Bitpaares XY, bei dem X und Y unabhängig sind.
Die für die Unabhängigkeit
erforderliche Bedingung gilt für die Vektoren,
die du hier siehst.
Das heißt, die Wahrscheinlichkeit
für jede mögliche Belegung der beiden Bits wird durch das Produkt der entsprechenden Wahrscheinlichkeiten
für die einzelnen Bits gegeben.
Zum Beispiel ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass beide
Bits den Wert null annehmen, gleich ein sechstel, was gleich ein
viertel mal zwei drittel ist,
und ebenso für die
anderen drei Möglichkeiten, die man einzeln nachprüfen kann.
Für den probabilistischen Zustand, den wir vorhin gesehen haben, bei dem
wir zwei Bits haben, die immer übereinstimmen und die Werte null und
eins mit Wahrscheinlichkeit ein halb annehmen,
haben wir hingegen keine Unabhängigkeit, und deshalb sagen wir, dass
die Bits korreliert sind.
Korrelation bedeutet einfach
das Fehlen von Unabhängigkeit.
Ein einfacher Weg, zu zeigen, dass die
beiden Bits nicht unabhängig sind, besteht darin, anzunehmen, dass sie es sind, und einen Widerspruch herzuleiten.
Genauer gesagt müssten, wenn die beiden
Bits unabhängig wären, Zahlen q0, q1, r0 und r1 existieren,
die Wahrscheinlichkeiten
für die beiden einzelnen Bits darstellen, sodass diese Gleichungen
hier erfüllt sind.
Das sind die Wahrscheinlichkeiten,
die aus unserem Vektor hervorgehen, und das sind die
Gleichungen, die aufgrund der Bedingung der Unabhängigkeit gelten müssen,
aber wenn wir uns diese
zweite Gleichheit hier ansehen, stellen wir fest, dass sie fordert, dass
q0 mal r1 gleich null ist,
aber das Produkt zweier reeller Zahlen kann
nur dann gleich null sein, wenn mindestens eine dieser
Zahlen selbst gleich null ist.
Das wird manchmal als
die Nullprodukt-Eigenschaft der reellen Zahlen bezeichnet.
Anders ausgedrückt: das Produkt zweier von null verschiedener reeller
Zahlen ist immer von null verschieden.
Diese Gleichheit hier
bedeutet also, dass entweder q0 gleich null oder r1 gleich null ist,
aber aus der ersten und der letzten Gleichheit sehen wir, dass keine
dieser beiden Alternativen möglich ist.
Wenn q0 gleich null ist, dann muss dieses Produkt null sein, aber es ist nicht null,
und wenn r1 gleich null ist,
dann muss dieses Produkt gleich null sein, aber das stimmt auch nicht.
Wir haben also einen Widerspruch
und schlussfolgern, dass X und Y nicht unabhängig sind, also korreliert sind.
Der Begriff der Unabhängigkeit,
den wir gerade besprochen haben, und insbesondere seine Formulierung in Form von Wahrscheinlichkeits-
vektoren, ist eng verwandt
mit einer Operation, die
auf Vektoren angewendet werden kann und als Tensorprodukt bekannt ist.
Tensorprodukte lassen sich
nicht nur für Vektoren, sondern auch für Matrizen definieren,
und tatsächlich kann der Begriff des Tensorprodukts definiert werden
für viele andere Arten von
mathematischen Objekten ebenfalls.
Sie können auf eine ziemlich abstrakte Weise beschrieben werden, die sowohl wichtig als auch
nützlich in der reinen Mathematik ist, aber wir können Tensorprodukte auch für Vektoren definieren
auf eine sehr einfache und konkrete Weise, und das ist der Weg, den
wir in dieser Lektion einschlagen werden.
Wenn wir zwei Spaltenvektoren Phi und Psi in den Formen haben, die du hier siehst, wobei sigma und gamma eine beliebige
Wahl von klassischen Zustandsmengen sind
oder Indizes, wenn du das bevorzugst, dann ist das Tensorprodukt dieser Vektoren der Vektor, den du hier siehst.
Wir gehen über alle Elemente
des kartesischen Produkts der beiden Mengen sigma und gamma, und der Eintrag dieses
Vektors, der entspricht
zu jedem Paar ab, das
hier als Zeichenkette geschrieben ist, ist gleich dem Produkt der
entsprechenden Einträge
dieser beiden Vektoren. Mit anderen Worten: der ab-Eintrag von Phi tensor Psi ist das Produkt des a-Eintrags
von Phi und des b-Eintrags von Psi,
und das ist die Bedeutung
dessen, was hier aufgeschrieben ist.
Im Wesentlichen ist das dieselbe Operation, die wir gerade vor wenigen Momenten gesehen haben, als wir die Unabhängigkeit besprochen haben
und jetzt geben wir ihr einfach einen Namen.
Hier ist genau dasselbe Beispiel,
das wir gerade eben gesehen haben, nun expliziter in
Begriffen des Tensorprodukts geschrieben.
Wieder gilt, dass ein Sechstel gleich einem Viertel mal einem Drittel ist, ein Zwölftel gleich einem Viertel
mal einem Drittel ist und so weiter.
Hier sind übrigens noch ein
paar alternative Schreibweisen für das Tensor-
produkt zweier Vektoren.
Wenn wir die Dirac-Notation verwenden und zwei Kets
nebeneinander schreiben, wie hier, bedeutet das das Tensorprodukt.
Du kannst dir das Tensorprodukt also als die Standardmethode vorstellen, zwei Spaltenvektoren miteinander zu multiplizieren.
Es würde keinen Sinn ergeben,
ein Produkt von Spaltenvektoren wie dieses im Sinne der Matrixmultiplikation zu betrachten, da die Dimensionen nicht stimmen,
es besteht also wirklich keine
Gefahr von Mehrdeutigkeit hier.
Wir können das Tensor-
produkt auch so innerhalb eines Kets schreiben, und es bedeutet
genau dasselbe.
Es ist das Tensorprodukt
der beiden Vektoren.
Die erste Schreibweise ist sehr gebräuchlich, und tatsächlich ist es vielleicht üblicher, ein Tensorprodukt so ohne das Tensorprodukt-Symbol zu schreiben
als das Symbol einzubeziehen. Die zweite Schreibweise ist
definitiv viel weniger gebräuchlich, kann aber manchmal sehr hilfreich sein, hauptsächlich
als Möglichkeit, den Bedarf an
zusätzlichen Klammern in bestimmten Situationen zu vermeiden.
Wir können Tensorprodukte auch
explizit in Form von tatsächlichen Zahlenspalten ausdrücken, wie du hier siehst,
wenn wir das Tensorprodukt dieser beiden Spaltenvektoren hier nehmen, dann erhalten wir diesen Vektor
und du kannst sehen, dass die Einträge hier Produkte der Einträge
aus diesen beiden Vektoren sind.
Die Reihenfolge der Einträge
des Tensorprodukts stimmt mit der
Definition von vorhin überein, vorausgesetzt, wir folgen der Konvention
die ich zuvor für die Anordnung der Elemente
von kartesischen Produktmengen beschrieben habe.
Diese Konvention zu befolgen ist gleichbedeutend damit,
die Indizes des ersten Vektors als
höherwertig anzusehen als die Indizes des zweiten Vektors,
sodass du sehen kannst, dass
beim Durchgehen der Einträge des Tensorprodukts zunächst alle Produkte mit dem ersten Eintrag des
ersten Vektors auf der linken Seite stehen,
nämlich alpha eins. Dann alle Produkte
mit dem zweiten Eintrag des Vektors auf der linken Seite,
nämlich alpha zwei und so weiter.
Hier ist ein Beispiel, bei dem
der Vektor auf der linken Seite drei Einträge und der Vektor auf der
rechten Seite vier Einträge hat, sodass wir klarer sehen können, was vor sich geht.
Wir haben drei Einträge im ersten Vektor, also beginnen wir damit, drei Kopien des zweiten Vektors aufzuschreiben, und dann multiplizieren wir jede dieser Kopien
mit dem entsprechenden Eintrag
im ersten Vektor wie hier.
Wir ziehen die Alphas nach innen wie hier, und dabei
multiplizieren wir nur Vektoren mit Skalaren
und schließlich entfernen wir die
Klammern aus den Kopien und bilden einen einzelnen Spalten-
vektor, wie du ihn hier siehst.
Als wichtige Anmerkung beachte, dass wir die folgenden Formeln für das Tensorprodukt von
Standardbasisvektoren haben.
Wenn wir das Tensor-
produkt von Ket a und Ket b nehmen, was wir mit
dem Tensorproduktsymbol oder ohne schreiben können, wie du hier siehst,
dann ist das Ergebnis einfach Ket ab.
Wenn wir ab als geordnetes Paar statt als Zeichenkette schreiben wollen, können wir das tun und erhalten
diesen Ausdruck hier,
aber es ist viel gebräuchlicher,
dies hier zu schreiben, wo wir die Klammern weglassen,
aber das Komma stehen lassen.
In gewissem Sinne ist
dieses hier mit der Klammer vielleicht korrekter, aber es ist eine ziemlich übliche
Konvention in der Mathematik,
dass Klammern entfernt werden, wenn sie nicht notwendig oder hilfreich sind.
Du kannst dir vorstellen, dass sie in diesem hier implizit enthalten sind, und es ist einfach übersichtlicher
und schöner anzusehen.
Das Tensorprodukt hat
eine wichtige Eigenschaft, nämlich dass es bilinear ist, und das bedeutet, dass es linear ist
in jedem der beiden Argumente, sofern das jeweils andere festgehalten wird.
Etwas detaillierter ist es
linear im ersten Argument, was durch diese beiden Gleichungen ausgedrückt wird, die du hier siehst,
die erste besagt, dass
wenn wir zwei Vektoren Phi1 und Phi2 addieren und dann das
Tensorprodukt mit Psi nehmen, wir dasselbe Ergebnis erhalten, als wenn wir das Tensorprodukt
mit Psi zuerst genommen und dann addiert hätten.
Die zweite besagt, dass wenn
wir einen Vektor Phi mit einem Skalar alpha multiplizieren und dann das
Tensorprodukt mit Psi nehmen,
das Ergebnis dasselbe ist, als ob wir zuerst das Tensorprodukt von Phi und Psi genommen und dann das Ergebnis mit alpha multipliziert hätten.
Und wir haben auch Linearität
im zweiten Argument, was dasselbe ist, außer dass die Rollen der beiden Argumente vertauscht sind.
Dass dieses Produkt bilinear ist,
lässt sich aus der Definition recht leicht überprüfen, aber es ist gut, es so aufzuschreiben, weil wir diese Formeln oft
verwenden werden.
Beachte übrigens, dass Skalare frei durch Tensorprodukte fließen, in dem Sinne, der durch diese
Gleichungen ausgedrückt wird, die du hier siehst.
Das heißt, es gibt keinen Unterschied
zwischen der Multiplikation des ersten Arguments mit einem
Skalar alpha, in diesem Fall der Multiplikation des zweiten
Arguments mit diesem Skalar,
oder der Multiplikation des gesamten
Ausdrucks mit diesem Skalar.
Diese Gleichheiten folgen aus
diesen beiden Gleichungen hier, und da es keinen
Unterschied zwischen diesen Vektoren gibt, können wir den
Ausdruck einfach so schreiben, wie du ihn hier siehst,
ohne Klammern, weil
es keine Notwendigkeit dafür gibt.
Sie fügen keine Klarheit hinzu
und beseitigen keine Mehrdeutigkeit, also entfernen wir sie einfach und
erhalten einen saubereren Ausdruck.
All das verallgemeinert sich
auf drei oder mehr Systeme.
Wir können das Tensorprodukt
von drei oder mehr Vektoren definieren, indem wir die Formel
für das Tensorprodukt zweier Vektoren auf natürliche Weise verallgemeinern,
was du hier ausgedrückt siehst. Jeder Eintrag des Tensorprodukts ergibt sich aus dem Produkt der
entsprechenden Einträge
der Vektoren, von denen wir
das Tensorprodukt nehmen.
Eine äquivalente Möglichkeit,
das Tensorprodukt von drei oder mehr Vektoren zu definieren,
besteht darin, es rekursiv zu tun und letztendlich auf die Definition
des Tensorprodukts zweier Vektoren zurückzufallen. Wenn n also mindestens drei ist, können wir uns das
Tensorprodukt von n Vektoren
Phi1 bis Phi n als das Tensorprodukt zwischen dem Vektor, den wir erhalten, indem wir
das Tensorprodukt der ersten n minus eins davon nehmen, mit dem letzten Vektor vorstellen,
und wenn du wissen möchtest,
was das Tensorprodukt der ersten n minus eins Vektoren ist, wendest du entweder die Formel
erneut an, falls n minus eins
mindestens drei ist, oder verwendest die Definition
von vorhin, falls n minus eins gleich zwei ist.
Die beiden Arten, über
Tensorprodukte von drei oder mehr Vektoren nachzudenken, sind äquivalent.
In diesem Fall, wenn wir
drei oder mehr Vektoren haben, von denen wir das Tensorprodukt nehmen, verwenden wir nicht den Begriff bilinear,
sondern stattdessen den Begriff multilinear,
aber die Idee ist dieselbe.
Das Tensorprodukt ist linear
in jeder der Positionen, sofern die Vektoren in
allen anderen Positionen
festgehalten sind. Weiter zu Messungen
mehrerer Systeme in probabilistischen Zuständen:
Wir erhalten sofort eine Spezifikation dafür, wie Messungen
bei mehreren Systemen funktionieren, indem wir sie einfach
gemeinsam als Einzelsysteme betrachten,
sofern alle
Systeme gemessen werden.
Als einfaches Beispiel nehmen wir an, dass wir zwei
Bits X und Y haben und dass sie gemeinsam in diesem probabilistischen
Zustand hier sind,
den wir zuvor gesehen haben. Wenn wir beide Bits messen, erhalten wir natürlich das Ergebnis 00,
also eine Null bei der ersten Messung und eine Null bei der zweiten Messung mit Wahrscheinlichkeit ein halb, und wir erhalten das Ergebnis 1,1
ebenfalls mit Wahrscheinlichkeit ein halb. Das ist ziemlich unkompliziert.
Im Wesentlichen ist das Messen aller Systeme äquivalent zum Messen
des gesamten zusammengesetzten Systems.
Wenn wir jedoch nicht alle
Systeme messen, sondern stattdessen nur
einige der Systeme messen, dann ist die Situation nicht
ganz so unmittelbar klar
Wir beschränken unsere Aufmerksamkeit erneut auf den Fall von nur zwei
Systemen, um das Wesentliche des Geschehens in einem
möglichst einfachen Rahmen zu sehen.
Wir können folgende Frage stellen: Angenommen, wir haben zwei Systeme, X und Y, die zusammen als Paar vorliegen
in einem bestimmten probabilistischen Zustand.
Was passiert, wenn wir
nur X messen und nichts mit Y machen?
Nun, wir können diese Frage mithilfe einiger grundlegender Wahrscheinlichkeitstheorie beantworten.
Zunächst wissen wir, dass die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass die Messung
ein bestimmtes Ergebnis liefert, durch diese Formel
gegeben sein muss, die du hier siehst.
Wir können uns die Wahrscheinlichkeiten für jeden der klassischen
Zustände des Paares XY so vorstellen, als ob wir beide gemessen hätten, und summieren über alle Wahrscheinlichkeiten
die damit konsistent sind, dass X sich in dem klassischen Zustand
a befindet, an dem wir interessiert sind.
Deshalb läuft die Summe hier nur über die klassischen Zustände b von Y.
Eine Möglichkeit, diese
Formel zu verstehen, ist, dass die Wahrscheinlichkeit, einen bestimmten klassischen
Zustand von X zu sehen, wenn wir ihn messen,
konsistent sein muss mit der Wahrscheinlichkeit, diesen Zustand zu sehen, wenn
wir auch Y gemessen hätten, obwohl wir das nicht getan haben,
das ist sehr natürlich und intuitiv. Die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass eine Messung von X ein bestimmtes Ergebnis liefert, kann möglicherweise davon abhängen, ob Y
auch gemessen wurde
oder nicht, unabhängig vom Ergebnis.
Das sagt uns also, welche
Wahrscheinlichkeiten für die verschiedenen möglichen
Messergebnisse gelten, aber was passiert mit Y bzw. unserem
Wissen über Y als Ergebnis?
Die Antwort ist, dass immer noch
eine gewisse Unsicherheit über den Zustand von Y bestehen kann,
als Ergebnis davon, dass wir X gemessen haben
und ein bestimmtes Ergebnis gesehen haben. Und diese Unsicherheit wird durch diese Formel hier für die bedingte Wahrscheinlichkeit dargestellt
dass Y sich in einem bestimmten
klassischen Zustand b befindet, gegeben dass X sich in einem klassischen Zustand befindet,
welchem klassischen Zustand a auch immer
wir gemessen haben.
Genauer gesagt ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass Y sich
in einem klassischen Zustand b befindet, gegeben dass X sich im klassischen Zustand a befindet,
gleich der Wahrscheinlichkeit,
dass X in a und Y in b ist, dividiert durch die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass X
sich im klassischen Zustand a befindet.
Wenn wir also X messen, werden wir
verschiedene klassische Zustände mit Wahrscheinlichkeiten sehen, die
durch diese Formel hier bestimmt werden
und je nach dem Ergebnis, das wir erhalten, kann noch eine gewisse Unsicherheit über den klassischen Zustand von Y bestehen, und
diese Unsicherheit spiegelt sich wider
durch diese Formel hier.
Es gibt tatsächlich eine sehr einfache
Möglichkeit, all das neu zu formulieren und Berechnungen
für spezifische Fälle mithilfe der Dirac-Notation durchzuführen,
und das geht so.
Wir beginnen damit, den
probabilistischen Zustand von XY als Vektor wie diesen aufzuschreiben, und
das ist vollkommen allgemein.
Die Einträge werden mit Pab bezeichnet und diese können beliebige Zahlen sein, solange der gesamte Vektor
ein Wahrscheinlichkeitsvektor ist.
Wir können den Ket ab als ein
Tensorprodukt ausdrücken, wie du es hier siehst, und dann können wir die
Bilinearität des Tensorprodukts nutzen
und speziell die Tatsache, dass es linear im zweiten Argument ist, um diesen Vektor
auszudrücken, wie du es hier siehst.
Was wir tun, ist effektiv die Standardbasisvektoren
auf der linken Seite zu isolieren und das, was wir
auf der rechten Seite benötigen, einzusetzen
damit das möglich ist, denn das wird enthüllen, was passiert, wenn wir
das erste System X messen.
Konkret ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
ein bestimmtes Ergebnis a zu erhalten, die Summe über alle Wahrscheinlichkeiten, die in der
Klammer neben dem Ket a erscheinen.
Und bedingt auf das Erhalten
eines bestimmten Ergebnisses a, ist der Wahrscheinlichkeitsvektor, der die verbleibende Unsicherheit über Y beschreibt,
der Vektor, der in
der Klammer neben a stand.
Außer dass wir ihn normieren müssen, um ihn zu einem Wahrscheinlichkeitsvektor zu machen, das heißt, dass wir
diesen Vektor dividieren müssen
durch die Summe der Einträge in diesem Vektor, um einen Wahrscheinlichkeitsvektor zu bilden.
Hier übrigens wird die Summe insgesamt
über c in gamma anstatt b genommen, nur um einen anderen Variablennamen zu verwenden, damit es keine Verwechslung geben wird
bezüglich des Gültigkeitsbereichs der
Variablen, wenn du so willst.
Die Summen im Zähler
und im Nenner sollten als separate Dinge betrachtet werden, und wir können jede Chance
einer Verwechslung darüber vermeiden
indem wir verschiedene
Variablen für die beiden Summen verwenden.
Hier ist ein kurzes Beispiel,
um zu veranschaulichen, wie das alles funktioniert.
Angenommen, XY ist ein Paar von Bits in diesem probabilistischen Zustand hier. Um zu verstehen, was passiert,
wenn wir das erste Bit messen
und nichts mit dem zweiten tun, schreiben wir den Vektor wie du es hier siehst, wobei Ket null und Ket
eins in der ersten Position
isoliert werden, genau wie wir
es vor wenigen Momenten beschrieben haben.
Die erste Möglichkeit ist,
dass das Messergebnis null ist und die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
dass das passiert, die Summe der Wahrscheinlichkeiten
innerhalb der Klammern ist
die mit dem Ket null tensoriert werden. Also erhalten wir ein Zwölftel plus ein Viertel, was ein Drittel ist, und
bedingt auf das Ergebnis null.
Wird der probabilistische Zustand von Y
zu diesem normierten Vektor, bzw. dividiert durch die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
die wir gerade berechnet haben, und so erhalten wir
diesen Vektor hier.
Die zweite Möglichkeit ist, dass das Messergebnis eins ist und die Berechnung
auf ähnliche Weise durchgeführt wird, indem der zweite Term in dem Ausdruck verwendet wird
anstatt des ersten Terms. Wenn du die Details überprüfen möchtest, pausiere das Video wie immer und nimm dir einen Moment dafür.
Du kannst dieselbe Art von
Berechnungen durchführen, um herauszufinden, was passiert, wenn
Y statt X gemessen wird.
Die Methode ist dieselbe, bis auf eine Symmetrie zwischen den beiden Systemen.
Diesmal schreiben wir den
Wahrscheinlichkeitsvektor so, indem wir die Standardbasisvektoren auf der rechten Seite isolieren, wie du hier siehst,
aber ansonsten funktioniert es
auf genau dieselbe Weise.
Du kannst diese Methode auch
für mehr als zwei Systeme verwenden.
Es kann ein wenig
unübersichtlich werden, alle erforderlichen Ausdrücke aufzuschreiben, aber konzeptuell ist es
genau dieselbe Idee.
Abschließend, für den Teil der Lektion
über klassische Information, werfen wir einen Blick auf Operationen
auf probabilistischen Zuständen
mehrerer Systeme. Wir folgen dabei derselben Argumentation, die wir nun schon ein paarmal gesehen haben.
Wir kommen zu dem Schluss, dass probabilistische Operationen auf mehreren Systemen genauso sind
wie probabilistische Operationen auf einzelnen Systemen, dargestellt
durch stochastische Matrizen.
Aber diesmal haben diese Matrizen
Zeilen und Spalten, die dem kartesischen Produkt der klassischen Zustandsmengen der einzelnen Systeme entsprechen.
Das heißt, wir betrachten ein
zusammengesetztes System einfach so, als wäre es ein einzelnes System, und greifen auf die Beschreibung zurück, wie probabilistische Operationen funktionieren
für einzelne Systeme aus
der vorherigen Lektion.
Hier ist ein Beispiel einer Operation namens controlled-NOT
Operation auf zwei Bits X und Y.
Dies ist tatsächlich eine deterministische Operation, und die Art, wie sie funktioniert, ist,
dass wenn X gleich eins ist, dann wird eine NOT-Operation auf Y ausgeführt
und andernfalls, wenn X gleich
null ist, passiert nichts.
Das Bit X wird manchmal
als Kontrollbit bezeichnet, weil es bestimmt, ob
die NOT-Operation auf Y angewendet wird oder nicht
und Y wird als Zielbit bezeichnet, weil es das Bit ist, auf das die NOT-Operation angewendet wird.
Du kannst dir auch vorstellen,
die Rollen von X und Y zu tauschen, sodass Y das Kontrollbit
wird und X das Ziel, aber das ist eine andere Operation
als die hier beschriebene, weil die Operation nicht
symmetrisch zwischen X und Y ist.
Beide werden
controlled-NOT Operationen genannt, und wir müssen nur angeben,
welches der Bits das Kontrollbit ist und
welches das Zielbit ist.
Diese Operation hat die Wirkung,
die du hier auf Standardbasiszustände siehst, und du kannst diese
Wirkung gegen die Definition überprüfen
der Operation. Und hier ist die Matrixdarstellung der Operation.
Wenn wir über diese Operation nachdenken, haben wir im Sinn, dass es
diese zwei separaten Bits gibt, die die Rollen spielen, die ich gerade beschrieben habe, wobei
X das Kontrollbit ist
und Y das Zielbit ist, aber es gibt eigentlich nichts
an dieser Wirkung hier oder dieser Matrixdarstellung,
das verlangt, dass wir
diese zwei Bits als separate Bits betrachten.
Wir könnten alternativ auch einfach
diese Operation als eine deterministische
Operation auf einem System mit vier klassischen Zuständen betrachten,
die wir beschlossen haben zu nennen:
0,0, 0,1, 1,0 und 1,1.
Hier ist ein weiteres Beispiel einer
probabilistischen Operation auf zwei Bits, die diesmal keine deterministische
Operation ist.
Die Operation setzt Y mit Wahrscheinlichkeit ein halb gleich X, und andernfalls geht es andersherum und X wird gleich Y gesetzt.
Diese Operation hat keinen speziellen Namen, sie dient nur als Beispiel.
Und hier ist die Matrixdarstellung dieser Operation.
Du kannst sehen, dass sie als Durchschnitt zweier Matrizen ausgedrückt werden kann, eine davon stellt die
deterministische Operation dar,
bei der Y auf den in X gespeicherten
Wert gesetzt wird, und die andere, die
X gleich Y setzt.
Hier sehen wir also, dass wir Durchschnitte stochastischer Matrizen nehmen können, um neue zu erhalten, genau wie in der vorherigen Lektion.
Nun betrachten wir
die folgende Frage. Angenommen, wir haben zwei
probabilistische Operationen, jede auf ihrem eigenen System,
wie üblich durch stochastische
Matrizen beschrieben, und um es genau zu sagen, nehmen wir an, dass M eine
probabilistische Operation ist
auf einem System X und N eine
probabilistische Operation auf einem System Y ist.
Die Frage ist: Wenn wir
gleichzeitig M auf X und N auf Y ausführen, wie beschreiben wir
den Effekt, den dies hat,
auf das zusammengesetzte System XY?
Wenn wir intuitiv einen Moment
darüber nachdenken: Wenn wir gleichzeitig
die zwei Operationen auf ihren eigenen Systemen ausführen,
führen wir tatsächlich
eine Operation auf dem zusammengesetzten System aus, also sollte sie durch
irgendeine stochastische Matrix beschrieben werden.
Die kurze Antwort auf diese
Frage ist, dass die Matrix durch das Tensorprodukt erhalten wird, nicht zwischen Vektoren wie
wir es zuvor besprochen haben,
sondern zwischen Matrizen, in diesem
Fall den Matrizen M und N.
Lass uns also ein paar Momente damit verbringen,
Tensorprodukte von Matrizen zu besprechen, und dann kehren wir
zu dieser Frage zurück.
Hier ist die Definition
des Tensorprodukts zwischen Matrizen, und sie ist dem Tensorprodukt zwischen Vektoren sehr ähnlich.
Wenn wir annehmen, dass die beiden
Matrizen, mit denen wir arbeiten, in den Formen geschrieben sind, die du hier siehst, sodass die Einträge von M
mit alpha ab bezeichnet werden, wobei a und b
über eine klassische Zustandsmenge sigma laufen und die Einträge von N
mit beta cd bezeichnet werden, wobei c und d
über eine klassische Zustandsmenge gamma laufen.
Dann ist das Produkt von M und N die Matrix, die du hier siehst.
Was wir haben, ist ähnlich
zum Tensorprodukt zwischen Vektoren.
die Zeilen und Spalten von M tensor N entsprechen Paaren von klassischen Zuständen, die hier als Zeichenketten geschrieben werden,
und die Einträge sind Produkte der entsprechenden Einträge von M und N.
Hier ist eine weitere Möglichkeit, es in Bezug auf die einzelnen
Einträge dieser Matrizen zu schreiben.
Der ac-bd-Eintrag von M tensor N ist das Produkt des ab-Eintrags
von M und des cd-Eintrags von N.
Es gibt eine weitere Möglichkeit,
M tensor N zu beschreiben, nämlich dass es die
eindeutige Matrix ist, die jeden Vektor der Form Phi tensor Psi transformiert
in das Tensorprodukt von M angewendet auf Phi mit N angewendet auf Psi, und das muss für jede Wahl
dieser Vektoren Phi und Psi gelten.
Eine Möglichkeit, darüber nachzudenken,
ist, dass das Tensorprodukt von Matrizen perfekt mit dem Tensorprodukt zwischen Vektoren harmoniert.
Das ist eine Gleichung, von der du
natürlich hoffen würdest, dass sie stimmt, und tatsächlich tut sie das.
In Bezug auf Matrizen, die
explizit aufgeschrieben sind, können wir das Tensorprodukt so definieren, wie du es hier siehst.
Es gibt viele Punkte in dieser Gleichung und sie sollen
das Muster veranschaulichen, welches dasselbe Muster ist,
das wir für Vektoren hatten, außer dass wir jetzt Zeilen und Spalten haben
anstatt nur Spaltenvektoren.
Falls es nicht klar ist, kann das
folgende Beispiel helfen.
Hier sprechen wir über
das Tensorprodukt zweier zwei-mal-zwei-Matrizen.
Wir schreiben zunächst vier
Kopien der zweiten Matrix auf, eine für jeden Eintrag der ersten Matrix.
Wir multiplizieren jede dieser
Kopien der zweiten Matrix mit dem entsprechenden
Eintrag der ersten Matrix,
und dann fassen wir alles in
eine einzige vier-mal-vier-Matrix zusammen, wie du hier siehst.
Wir können auch das
Tensorprodukt von drei oder mehr Matrizen auf analoge Weise definieren, und vielleicht der einfachste
Weg, dies auszudrücken,
ist so, wie du es hier siehst,
wo wir eine Formel für jeden Eintrag des Tensorprodukts haben, die einfach das Produkt
der entsprechenden Einträge ist.
Du kannst auch das Tensorprodukt von drei oder mehr Matrizen rekursiv in Bezug auf das Tensorprodukt von nur zwei Matrizen definieren, genauso wie wir es für Vektoren hatten.
Und ein letzter Hinweis ist,
dass das Tensorprodukt von Matrizen multiplikativ ist, was bedeutet, dass ein
Produkt von Tensorprodukten
gleich dem Tensorprodukt
der Produkte ist.
Du kannst das
als Verallgemeinerung der Formel von vor einigen Momenten für die Wirkung des Tensorprodukts von Matrizen betrachten
auf Tensorprodukte von Vektoren. Und auch das ist etwas, das wir
sicherlich hoffen würden zu stimmen, und wir können froh sein, dass es so ist
und wir werden von dieser
Tatsache Gebrauch machen, wann immer wir es brauchen.
Und jetzt können wir zu
der Frage von vorhin zurückkehren, die fragt, wie wir
die Wirkung der Ausführung einer Operation M auf einem System X beschreiben
und einer Operation N auf dem System Y zusammen als eine Operation
auf dem zusammengesetzten System XY.
Und die Antwort auf diese
Frage ist, dass die Wirkung durch das
Tensorprodukt von M und N beschrieben wird.
Tensorprodukte repräsentieren diesmal Unabhängigkeit zwischen Operationen im Gegensatz zu dem, was wir
zuvor für Wahrscheinlichkeitsvektoren gesehen haben.
Hier ist ein kurzes Beispiel. Angenommen, wir führen
die probabilistische Operation, die durch diese Matrix beschrieben wird, auf einem Bit X aus.
Dies ist zufällig eine Operation,
die wir in Lektion eins gesehen haben, und wir führen gleichzeitig
eine NOT-Operation auf einem Bit Y durch.
Die kombinierte Operation auf dem Paar XY wird daher durch das Tensorprodukt der Matrizen dargestellt, die diesen beiden Operationen entsprechen.
Hier ist die eine auf X und
hier ist die NOT-Operation auf Y und wir erhalten diese Matrix,
die du hier siehst.
Und du kannst sehen, dass dies
tatsächlich eine stochastische Matrix ist, und das wird immer der Fall sein.
Das Tensorprodukt von zwei
beliebigen stochastischen Matrizen oder einer beliebigen Anzahl von stochastischen
Matrizen wird immer stochastisch sein.
Es ist eine sehr häufige Situation,
dass wir auf eine Situation treffen, in der eine Operation
auf einem System durchgeführt wird und mit einem anderen System nichts gemacht wird.
In dieser Situation folgen wir genau der gleichen Vorschrift mit dem Verständnis, dass Nichtstun durch die Einheitsmatrix dargestellt wird.
Wenn wir zum Beispiel zwei Bits X und
Y haben und das Bit X auf den Nullzustand zurücksetzen, was dasselbe ist
wie die Ausführung der konstanten
Null-Funktion auf X, und wir mit Y nichts machen, dann ist die resultierende Operation auf dem Paar XY
durch dieses Tensorprodukt
hier dargestellt.
All das verallgemeinert sich
auf eine beliebige Anzahl von Systemen und wir werden einige weitere Beispiele sehen, wenn wir uns dem Quantenbereich zuwenden, der auf genau die gleiche Weise funktioniert
außer dass wir unitäre Matrizen anstelle von stochastischen Matrizen haben, und das reicht über
klassische Information fürs Erste.
Jetzt werden wir unsere Aufmerksamkeit
auf Quanteninformation richten und wie sie für mehrere Systeme funktioniert.
Das Muster ist dasselbe wie es
für klassische Information war.
Wir können mehrere Quantensysteme als einzelne zusammengesetzte Systeme betrachten und das anwenden, was wir
aus der vorherigen Lektion wissen.
Wieder werden Tensorprodukte
eine Schlüsselrolle spielen, und insgesamt erhalten wir eine Beschreibung dafür, wie Quanteninformation
bei mehreren Systemen funktioniert.
Das ist sehr analog
und mathematisch ähnlich zu dem, was wir gerade für
klassische Information gesehen haben.
Wir beginnen mit Quantenzuständen.
Quantenzustände mehrerer Systeme werden durch Spaltenvektoren mit komplexen Einträgen
und euklidischer Norm gleich eins dargestellt
genau wie Quantenzustände
einzelner Systeme.
Diesmal entsprechen die Indizes
der Quantenzustandsvektoren dem kartesischen Produkt der klassischen Zustandsmengen
der einzelnen Systeme,
denn das ist wieder
die klassische Zustandsmenge des zusammengesetzten Systems.
Wenn zum Beispiel X und Y qubits sind, dann ist die klassische Zustandsmenge
für das Paar XY zusammen das kartesische Produkt des
binären Alphabets mit sich selbst,
was wir uns als
die Menge aller binären Zeichenketten der Länge zwei vorstellen können.
Diese Vektoren, die du hier siehst, sind also alles Beispiele für Quantenzustandsvektoren von XY.
Wenn wir möchten, können wir diese Vektoren alternativ so schreiben, wobei wir einen separaten
Ket für jedes qubit haben
bei dem das Tensorprodukt
zwischen ihnen implizit ist.
Oder wir können auch das
Tensorproduktsymbol explizit so schreiben, wenn du das bevorzugst.
Und eine weitere Möglichkeit ist,
die Kets mit den Namen der Systeme
zu indizieren, die sie repräsentieren, so wie hier.
Und du kannst das mit
dem Tensorproduktsymbol oder ohne machen.
Das kann manchmal sehr hilfreich sein, um den Überblick zu behalten.
Das sind nur verschiedene Schreibweisen, um dieselben Vektoren auszudrücken, und wir können diejenige wählen, die wir wollen, die wir bevorzugen oder
die am sinnvollsten ist
für die jeweilige Situation. Wenn die Dinge zum Beispiel komplizierter werden, könnten wir entscheiden, dass eine dieser
Schreibweisen mehr Klarheit bringt
und wir können frei
jede Wahl treffen, die wir möchten.
Tensorprodukte von Quantenzustandsvektoren sind ebenfalls Quantenzustandsvektoren.
Im Fall von zwei Systemen zum Beispiel: Wenn Phi ein Quantenzustandsvektor
eines Systems X ist und Psi ein Quantenzustandsvektor eines Systems Y,
dann ist das Tensorprodukt von Phi und Psi ein Quantenzustandsvektor von XY.
Wir nennen solche Zustände Produktzustände, und ähnlich wie im klassischen Wahrscheinlichkeitsrahmen repräsentieren sie Unabhängigkeit
zwischen den Systemen X und Y.
Wenn zum Beispiel eine Person ein Labor
in einem Teil der Welt hat und ein System X erstellt und es auf den Quantenzustand Phi initialisiert
und eine andere Person in
einem anderen Teil der Welt unabhängig ein System Y auf den Quantenzustand Psi initialisiert,
wenn wir dann entscheiden, XY als ein einzelnes System zu betrachten, obwohl es zwei Teile in verschiedenen Teilen der Welt sind,
dann befindet sich das zusammengesetzte System XY
im Zustand Phi tensor Psi.
Das lässt sich alles auf
mehr als zwei Systeme auf natürliche Weise verallgemeinern.
Wenn wir Quantenzustände
Psi1 bis PsiN separater Systeme X1 bis Xn haben, dann stellt das Tensorprodukt dieser n Vektoren
einen Quantenzustand dar, der wieder ein Produktzustand des zusammengesetzten Systems X1 bis Xn genannt wird.
Hier ist ein Beispiel für einen
Quantenzustand von zwei qubits.
Obwohl es auf den ersten Blick vielleicht nicht so aussieht, ist es ein Beispiel für einen Produktzustand, weil wir
es als Tensorprodukt schreiben können, wie du hier siehst.
Es ist also ein Beispiel für einen
Produktzustand – unabhängig davon, wie er geschrieben wird, ist entscheidend, ob
es möglich ist oder nicht, ihn als Tensorprodukt zu schreiben.
Dieser Quantenzustand jedoch, der wieder ein Zustand von zwei
qubits ist, ist kein Produktzustand.
Er ähnelt im Geist
dem Beispiel, das wir im Wahrscheinlichkeitsrahmen gesehen haben, mit zwei perfekt korrelierten zufälligen Bits,
und dasselbe Argument zeigt, dass er nicht als
Tensorprodukt geschrieben werden kann.
Also lass uns das hierher verschieben und uns das Argument etwas genauer ansehen.
Stellen wir uns vor, wir könnten
diesen Zustand als Tensorprodukt von
zwei Vektoren Phi und Psi schreiben.
Der Eintrag, der
dem klassischen Zustand 0,1 entspricht, ist null für diesen Vektor, was wir einfach durch Hinsehen erkennen können.
Das würde jedoch implizieren, wenn der Vektor ein Tensorprodukt zweier Vektoren wäre, dass der Null-Eintrag von Phi
mal dem Eins-Eintrag von Psi
gleich null wäre, aber das bedeutet, dass entweder
der Null-Eintrag von Phi oder der Eins-Eintrag von Psi gleich null ist
oder beide gleich null sein könnten, aber das widerspricht der Tatsache,
dass diese beiden Produkte hier beide ungleich null sein müssen.
Sie sind gleich eins
durch Wurzel zwei. Das Argument ist tatsächlich
nahezu identisch mit dem, das wir im Wahrscheinlichkeitsrahmen hatten.
Es gibt dabei nichts genuin
Quantenmechanisches.
In jedem Fall stellen wir fest, dass der ursprüngliche Zustand kein Produktzustand ist.
Beachte, dass es nicht wichtig ist,
dass diese beiden Zahlen hier eins durch Wurzel zwei sind.
Alles, was zählt, ist, dass
beide Werte ungleich null sind.
Dieser besondere Quantenzustand
ist ein sehr interessanter. Er ist ein Beispiel für einen
verschränkten Zustand zweier Qubits.
Wir werden später in der Serie
mehr über Verschränkung sprechen.
Verschränkung kann kompliziert sein, besonders wenn wir
über Quantenzustände in der allgemeinen Formulierung
der Quanteninformation sprechen,
aber hier in der vereinfachten Beschreibung der Quanteninformation ist Verschränkung gleichbedeutend mit einem Mangel an Unabhängigkeit.
Bei einem Quantenzustandsvektor gilt also:
wenn er kein Produktzustand ist, ist er ein verschränkter Zustand,
und dieser bestimmte Zustand
wird gemeinhin als
das archetypische Beispiel eines verschränkten Quantenzustands betrachtet.
Und tatsächlich denken wir manchmal
daran, dass dieser Zustand eine Einheit der Verschränkung repräsentiert, besonders wenn wir
über Verschränkung nachdenken
als eine Ressource, die genutzt werden kann,
um interessante Dinge zu tun.
Der Quantenzustand, über den
wir gerade gesprochen haben, ist einer der vier sogenannten Bell-Zustände, die du hier sehen kannst,
zusammen mit den Namen,
die für diese Zustände üblicherweise verwendet werden: Phi plus, Phi minus,
Psi plus und Psi minus.
Sie sind alle verschränkt
und bilden tatsächlich eine Basis für den Raum aller
Vektoren, die Zustände zweier Qubits darstellen.
Diese vier Vektoren zusammen
werden also die Bell-Basis genannt.
Es ist eine sehr häufig
anzutreffende Sammlung von Quantenzuständen, benannt
zu Ehren von John Bell, einem Physiker, der
sehr wichtige Beiträge geleistet hat
zur Untersuchung der Verschränkung in den 1960er Jahren.
Hier sind einige bekannte Beispiele für Quantenzustände dreier Qubits.
Das erste wird GHZ-Zustand genannt.
Er ähnelt dem Phi
plus-Zustand, den wir gerade gesehen haben, nur für drei Qubits statt zwei.
Das zweite Beispiel heißt W-Zustand und sieht aus, wie du es hier siehst – er ist gleichmäßig über
die drei Binärstrings verteilt,
der Länge drei, die genau
ein auf eins gesetztes Bit haben.
Keiner dieser Zustände ist ein Produktzustand und beide haben interessante Eigenschaften und kommen als Beispiele recht häufig vor, es lohnt sich also, sie zu kennen,
und wir werden sie noch wiedersehen.
Als nächstes sprechen wir über
Messungen von Systemen in Quantenzuständen.
Wenn wir derselben Überlegung folgen,
der wir bisher in der Lektion gefolgt sind, nämlich mehrere Systeme
zu betrachten
als wären sie einzelne Systeme, gelangen wir unmittelbar zu einer Beschreibung, wie Messungen an
mehreren Quantensystemen funktionieren,
vorausgesetzt, dass alle
Systeme gemessen werden.
Das heißt, wenn wir einen
Quantenzustandsvektor Psi haben, der einen Quantenzustand
eines n-Tupels von Systemen darstellt,
X1 bis Xn, und wir das gesamte
zusammengesetzte System messen, was gleichwertig damit ist, zu messen,
jedes der einzelnen Systeme, dann ist jedes mögliche n-Tupel
von klassischen Zuständen das Ergebnis der Messung
mit einer Wahrscheinlichkeit gleich
dem Betragsquadrat des Eintrags von Psi, der
diesem n-Tupel entspricht.
Wenn wir zum Beispiel
ein Systemepaar XY in diesem Quantenzustand hier haben und wir beide Systeme messen,
dann erhalten wir das Ergebnis Null Herz, also Null für die Messung von X und Herz für die Messung von Y,
mit einer Wahrscheinlichkeit von neun Fünfundzwanzigsteln, und wir erhalten das Ergebnis Eins
Pik mit einer Wahrscheinlichkeit von 16/25.
Das ist tatsächlich ganz unkompliziert. Wir ignorieren im Wesentlichen die Tatsache, dass dies zwei getrennte Systeme sind, und betrachten sie als
wären sie ein einziges System,
aber das wirft die
folgende natürliche Frage auf, die wir bereits
im klassischen Kontext betrachtet haben.
Angenommen, wir haben zwei Systeme X und Y, die zusammen
in einem bestimmten Quantenzustand sind, und wir messen nicht beide, sondern
messen nur ein System.
Nehmen wir an, wir messen das System X und machen mit Y nichts.
Natürlich können wir auch fragen, was passiert, wenn wir Y und nicht
X messen, und allgemeiner, was passiert, wenn wir
drei oder mehr Systeme haben
und wir eine echte Teilmenge davon messen. Aber sobald wir eine
Antwort auf diese Frage haben, haben wir auch Antworten auf
jene Fragen.
Wir wissen, dass im Allgemeinen
ein Quantenzustandsvektor des Paares XY die
Form annimmt, die du hier siehst, unter der üblichen Annahme, dass sigma und gamma
die klassischen Zustandsmengen
von X bzw. Y sind.
Die Einträge dieses Vektors werden
durch alpha ab bezeichnet, wobei a und b über alle möglichen Kombinationen laufen,
und es können beliebige komplexe Zahlen sein, die diesen Vektor
zu einem Einheitsvektor machen.
Wir wissen bereits, dass wenn
beide Systeme gemessen werden, wir die Wahrscheinlichkeiten für die verschiedenen möglichen Ergebnisse erhalten,
indem wir das Betragsquadrat des entsprechenden Eintrags nehmen.
Wenn also nur X gemessen wird, dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
ein bestimmtes Ergebnis a zu erhalten, durch diesen Ausdruck gegeben,
wir summieren einfach über alle
möglichen Ergebnisse b, die erhalten werden könnten,
wenn Y ebenfalls gemessen würde, obwohl das nicht der Fall war.
Der Gedanke ist derselbe wie
im probabilistischen Kontext.
Die Wahrscheinlichkeit, ein
bestimmtes Ergebnis zu erhalten, wenn X gemessen wird, kann
unmöglich davon abhängen, ob Y ebenfalls gemessen wurde oder nicht.
Das sagt uns also,
welche Wahrscheinlichkeiten für die verschiedenen möglichen Ergebnisse gelten.
Außerdem wird es eine gewisse
Änderung im Zustand von Y geben, als Folge davon, dass
diese Messung an X durchgeführt und ein bestimmtes Ergebnis erhalten wurde.
Schauen wir uns also an, wie das funktioniert.
Ähnlich wie in der
probabilistischen Situation können wir den
Quantenzustandsvektor Psi ausdrücken, wie du es hier siehst
wobei Phi a dieser Vektor für jede Wahl eines klassischen Zustands a des Systems X ist,
wir verwenden dabei die Bilinearität
des Tensorprodukts, genau wie zuvor.
Nur haben wir jetzt gewählt, diese
verschiedenen Vektoren Phi a zu nennen, der Einfachheit halber.
Wir haben bereits festgestellt, dass die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass die Messung
jedes mögliche Ergebnis a liefert, so ist, wie du es hier siehst,
aber jetzt können wir sehen, dass diese Wahrscheinlichkeit gleich dem quadrierten
Euklidischen Norm des Vektors Phi a ist,
und nun, als Folge der Messung von X, die ein bestimmtes Ergebnis a liefert, haben wir, dass der Quantenzustand
des zusammengesetzten Systems XY
zu diesem Zustand wird, den
du hier siehst.
Genau wie bei einzelnen Systemen kollabiert der Zustand im Wesentlichen, aber er kollabiert
nicht vollständig im Allgemeinen,
er kollabiert nur so weit, wie es nötig ist, um konsistent
mit der Messung von X zu sein, die das Ergebnis a liefert.
Der Quantenzustand von Y wird zu normiertem Phi a, das bedeutet, dass wir
durch seine Euklidische Norm dividieren
damit er ein Einheitsvektor wird. Das ist analog zu dem, was in der
probabilistischen Situation passiert ist, wo wir anstatt durch die Euklidische Norm zu dividieren,
durch die Summe
der Einträge von Phi a dividiert haben, um einen Wahrscheinlichkeitsvektor zu erhalten.
Aber hier, weil wir
von Quantenzuständen sprechen, dividieren wir durch die Euklidische Norm,
um einen Quantenzustandsvektor zu erhalten.
Schauen wir uns ein paar Beispiele an, um zu sehen, wie das
für einen bestimmten Zustand funktioniert.
Hier ist der Zustand, den wir betrachten werden. Wir nehmen an, dass X und Y qubits sind und sie sich in diesem bestimmten Zustand Psi befinden.
Und nehmen wir an, dass X gemessen wird.
Wir beginnen damit, den Zustand
Psi zu schreiben, wie du es hier siehst, wobei wir effektiv die
Standardbasisfaktoren von X isolieren
und sie mit dem verbinden, was wir brauchen, um den ursprünglichen Zustand zu erhalten.
Genau wie in der allgemeinen
Beschreibung von eben.
Die Wahrscheinlichkeit, das Ergebnis null zu erhalten, ist das Quadrat der Euklidischen Norm
dieses Vektors hier.
Das, womit wir ket null in unserem Ausdruck des Vektors Psi verbinden.
Und so beträgt die Wahrscheinlichkeit drei Viertel, und unter der Bedingung,
das Ergebnis null zu erhalten.
Wird der Quantenzustand
des Paares XY zu diesem, wobei wir den
mit ket null verbundenen Vektor normieren,
und das ist äquivalent dazu,
durch die Quadratwurzel der Wahrscheinlichkeit zu dividieren, die
wir gerade berechnet haben.
Wir können dann vereinfachen
und das ist, was wir erhalten.
Die Wahrscheinlichkeit, das
Messergebnis eins zu erhalten, wird auf ähnliche Weise berechnet.
Wir nehmen das Quadrat der Euklidischen Norm
dieses Vektors hier. Das, was mit ket
eins in unserem Ausdruck von Psi verbunden ist
und die resultierende
Wahrscheinlichkeit ist ein Viertel, was natürlich so sein muss, da unsere Wahrscheinlichkeiten
sich zu eins summieren müssen.
In diesem Fall wird der Quantenzustand von XY zu diesem, wobei wir wieder normieren, indem wir durch die Euklidische Norm dividieren
damit wir diesen Quantenzustandsvektor
als Ergebnis erhalten.
Dieselbe Methode wird
symmetrisch verwendet, wenn Y anstatt X gemessen wird.
Hier ist der ursprüngliche Quantenzustandsvektor, und diesmal, weil Y
anstatt X gemessen wird,
drücken wir den Vektor Psi
so aus, wie du es hier siehst, wobei wir diesmal die
Standardbasisvektoren von Y isolieren
anstatt von X, und sie mit dem verbinden,
was wir brauchen, um einen Ausdruck von Psi zu erhalten.
Wenn wir die Berechnung durchführen, die du selbst überprüfen kannst,
indem du das Video pausierst.
Sehen wir, dass die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
das Ergebnis null zu erhalten, diesmal Phi8 ist, und hier ist
der Quantenzustandsvektor,
der sich ergibt unter der Bedingung,
dass dieses Ergebnis erzielt wird.
Und die Wahrscheinlichkeit, das
Ergebnis eins zu erhalten, beträgt drei Achtel, in welchem Fall das
unser Quantenzustandsvektor ist.
Du kannst genau dieselbe Methode verwenden, wenn du mehr als zwei Systeme hast und eine echte Teilmenge
davon gemessen wird.
Und es gibt ein Beispiel
im Lehrbuchinhalt für diese Lektion, das du
dir ansehen kannst, wenn du interessiert bist.
Kurz gesagt, wir können die Systeme immer in zwei separate Gruppen aufteilen, die, die gemessen werden,
und die, die es nicht werden.
Und sobald wir das getan haben, greifen wir auf die
Methode zurück, die ich gerade beschrieben habe, und so funktionieren Messungen bei mehreren Quantensystemen.
Und jetzt kommen wir schließlich zu unitären
Operationen auf mehreren Systemen.
Mit derselben grundlegenden Idee, dass mehrere Systeme als einzelne zusammengesetzte Systeme betrachtet werden können.
Schlussfolgern wir, was du
hier auf dem Bildschirm geschrieben siehst: Quantenoperationen auf zusammengesetzten Systemen werden durch unitäre Matrizen dargestellt
genau wie bei einzelnen Systemen, und insbesondere entsprechen die Zeilen und Spalten dieser unitären Matrizen dem kartesischen Produkt
der klassischen Zustandsmengen der jeweiligen Sammlung von
Systemen, über die wir sprechen.
Wenn wir zum Beispiel ein System X haben,
dessen klassische Zustände eins, zwei und drei sind, und Y ein qubit ist,
dann ist die Matrix, die du hier siehst, ein Beispiel für eine unitäre Matrix, die eine
Operation auf dem Paar XY darstellt.
Die Details, wie wir
kartesische Produkte ordnen, worüber wir vorher gesprochen haben, spielen für
dieses Beispiel keine wirkliche Rolle – es ist einfach eine sechs mal sechs Matrix,
die zufällig unitär ist.
Es ist nichts Besonderes daran, obwohl sie aus ein paar
wichtigen Matrizen aufgebaut ist.
Der Punkt ist, dass du
jede beliebige sechs mal sechs unitäre Matrix wählen könntest und sie würde
eine unitäre Operation auf XY darstellen.
Wenn wir eine Sammlung von
unitären Operationen anwenden, jede unabhängig auf ihr eigenes System, dann ist die Wirkung von allen zusammen
auf das zusammengesetzte System
durch das Tensorprodukt gegeben.
Und hier auf dem Bildschirm kannst du eine genauere
Aussage zu dieser Tatsache sehen.
Wenn unsere unitären Operationen durch die unitären Matrizen U1 bis Un beschrieben werden, eine für jedes unserer Systeme,
dann ist die kombinierte Wirkung
auf das zusammengesetzte System durch das Tensorprodukt
von U1 bis Un gegeben.
Ähnlich wie im probabilistischen Fall ist ein wichtiges Beispiel, dass
wir eine unitäre Operation anwenden
U auf ein System X und wir
nichts mit einem anderen System Y machen.
Die Operation auf XY, die wir erhalten, ist U tensoriert mit der Identitätsmatrix.
Die Identitätsmatrix
beschreibt, dass nichts mit Y gemacht wird.
Manchmal ist es hilfreich, explizit zu schreiben, dass diese Identitätsmatrix
dem System Y entspricht, nur um die Formeln klarer zu machen.
Eine Möglichkeit ist,
der Identitätsmatrix einen tiefgestellten Index wie diesen zu geben, der das System angibt, auf das sie wirkt.
Wenn es klar genug ist, verwenden wir normalerweise keinen
tiefgestellten Index, aber wenn die Dinge komplizierter werden, kann er sehr hilfreich sein.
Und wir können auch den
symmetrischen Fall betrachten, wo eine unitäre
Operation V auf Y angewendet wird und nichts mit X gemacht wird,
und diesmal wird die resultierende
unitäre Operation auf XY durch dieses
Tensorprodukt hier dargestellt.
Und auch hier können wir einen tiefgestellten Index auf die
Identitätsmatrix setzen, wenn es hilft.
Hier sind ein paar konkrete Beispiele.
Wenn X und Y qubits sind und wir
eine Hadamard-Operation auf X durchführen und nichts mit Y machen, erhalten wir die Matrix, die du hier siehst.
Wenn wir andererseits die Hadamard-Operation auf Y durchführen und nichts mit X machen, ist die Reihenfolge des Tensorprodukts
umgekehrt.
Und so erhalten wir die Matrix,
die du hier siehst.
Nicht jede unitäre Operation
auf einem zusammengesetzten System lässt sich als Tensorprodukt ausdrücken.
Wenn wir ein Tensorprodukt haben,
dann haben wir Unabhängigkeit.
Und es gibt einige ziemlich
grundlegende Beispiele von Operationen, die
sicherlich nicht unabhängig auf mehrere Systeme wirken.
Wenn zum Beispiel X und Y
die gleiche klassische Zustandsmenge haben, die irgendeine
klassische Zustandsmenge sigma sein kann,
dann können wir über die
Swap-Operation auf dem Paar XY nachdenken.
Diese Operation ändert die Reihenfolge der beiden Systeme nicht, wir haben immer noch X links
und Y rechts, sondern sie stellt
das Vertauschen der Inhalte dar
der beiden Systeme. Hier kannst du das ausgedrückt sehen
in Form einer Gleichung, wo wir ein Tensorprodukt
von zwei Quantenzuständen haben.
Eine andere Möglichkeit, es zu schreiben, ist als
Matrix, wie wir hier sehen.
Du kannst dir diese
Beschreibung so vorstellen, dass sie dir sagt, was mit Standardbasisvektoren passiert.
Und sobald wir wissen, was
mit Standardbasisvektoren passiert, wissen wir durch Linearität, was mit
beliebigen Quantenzuständen passiert,
was tatsächlich auch für
diesen Ausdruck hier gilt.
Diese spezielle Operation hier ist also sowohl eine deterministische Operation als auch eine unitäre Operation.
Wenn X und Y zum Beispiel qubits sind, erhalten wir diese Matrix-
darstellung hier.
Hier ist eine interessante Verbindung
zwischen der Swap-Operation und den vier Bell-Zuständen, die hier
der Einfachheit halber gezeigt werden.
Die Swap-Operation lässt die
ersten drei davon unverändert, aber sie setzt ein Minuszeichen vor
den Psi-minus-Zustand,
es gibt also etwas
Besonderes an diesem.
Du kannst diese Gleichungen direkt überprüfen, indem du dir diese Vektoren anschaust und überlegst, was
für die Standardbasiszustände passiert
das Vertauschen der beiden klassischen Zustände für die ersten drei Bell-
Zustände ändert nichts – wir erhalten denselben Zustand, mit dem wir begonnen haben.
Im vierten Fall jedoch verschiebt sich das Minuszeichen effektiv
von einem Term zum anderen, wenn wir das Vertauschen der klassischen Zustände durchführen,
und das ist äquivalent dazu, den Vektor mit minus eins zu multiplizieren.
Die Durchführung der Swap-Operation holt also sozusagen ein Minuszeichen
aus diesem vierten Bell-Zustand heraus.
Wir werden später mehr über
diese Gleichungen sagen, aber jetzt gehen wir weiter zu
einem anderen Typ von Operation, nämlich einer kontrollierten Operation.
Wir nehmen an, dass X ein qubit ist und Y ein beliebiges System ist.
Wenn U eine unitäre Operation auf Y ist, dann ist eine kontrollierte U-Operation auf XY die Operation, die
hier ausgedrückt wird.
Zuerst mit der direkten Notation und dann mit dem, was man
als Blockmatrix bezeichnet – stell dir vor, dass du
diese größere Matrix
mit den kleineren auffüllst, wobei diese Nullen wirklich Matrizen
darstellen, die mit Nullen gefüllt sind.
Jeder dieser vier Blöcke stellt also eine Matrix dar, deren Anzahl
von Zeilen und Spalten mit der Anzahl
der klassischen Zustände von Y übereinstimmt.
Die Idee einer kontrollierten Operation, die wir bereits
im klassischen Kontext kennengelernt haben, als wir eine
kontrollierte NOT-Operation besprochen haben,
ist, dass wenn X auf null gesetzt ist,
nichts mit Y passiert.
Aber wenn X auf eins gesetzt ist,
wird U auf Y angewendet.
X wird also als das Steuer-qubit bezeichnet, und Y wird als Zielsystem bezeichnet, das im Allgemeinen
kein qubit sein muss.
Als konkretes Beispiel,
das ich gerade erwähnt habe, haben wir eine kontrollierte NOT-Operation.
Wenn das erste qubit auf
null gesetzt ist, passiert nichts. Und wenn das erste qubit auf eins gesetzt ist, wird eine NOT-Operation oder gleichwertig dazu
eine Sigma-X-Operation auf
das zweite qubit angewendet.
Und hier ist ihre Matrixdarstellung.
Wir sprechen hier von zwei qubits, also könnten wir genauso gut
entscheiden, dass das zweite qubit das Steuer-qubit und das
erste das Ziel ist.
Um diese Operation zu beschreiben, tauschen wir einfach die Reihenfolge
im Tensorprodukt aus, und das Ergebnis ist die Matrix,
die du hier siehst.
Wenn wir statt einer kontrollierten-NOT-Operation eine kontrollierte Sigma-
Z- oder kontrollierte-Z-Operation betrachten.
Erhalten wir diese Matrixdarstellung hier. Und bei dieser spielt es
keine Rolle, welches das Steuer-qubit und welches das Ziel ist.
Wir erhalten auf beide Arten dasselbe Ergebnis.
Wir können weitergehen und eine kontrollierte Swap-Operation betrachten.
Dabei sprechen wir
vom Vertauschen zweier qubits, sodass wir am Ende drei qubits haben, wenn wir das Steuer-qubit einbeziehen.
Jede Matrixdarstellung
sieht so aus.
Es ist eine ziemlich besondere Operation, die als Fredkin-Operation oder häufiger als Fredkin-gate bekannt ist.
Wenn wir darüber nachdenken
als ein gate in einem circuit, werden wir circuits in der nächsten Lektion besprechen.
Das letzte Beispiel ist eine kontrollierte,
kontrollierte-NOT-Operation, die wiederum eine
Operation auf drei qubits ist.
Und hier ist ihre Matrixdarstellung. Diese Operation ist viel besser
bekannt als Toffoli-Operation oder Toffoli-gate.
Wir werden sie weiter besprechen
und sehen, warum sowohl sie als auch die Fredkin-Operation sehr wichtige
Operationen in einer späteren Lektion sind.
Und das ist das Ende der zweiten Lektion. In dieser Lektion haben wir besprochen, wie Quanteninformation bei mehreren Systemen funktioniert.
Ich hoffe, du schließt dich mir bald für
die dritte Lektion an, die sich mit quantum circuits,
Protokollen und Spielen befasst.
Tschüss bis dahin.